. Let's go to the phones and see if our phone
system is functioning at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50.
Let me go first to our caller from the 6 5
1 area code who is calling today from 6 5
1.
David, is this me?
Yes, it is.
Hi, this is Mike from the Twin Cities, Minnesota.
Big fan of your show.
So my question to you today is, as I'm sure
you've heard, there's recently there's been
like some conservative infighting going on
between the traditional branches of conservatism,
like Ben SHAPIRO, Charlie Kirt and a more
like right wing nationalistic form of conservatism,
basically neo-Nazis, mostly led by a guy named
Nick one.tel's.
Right.
And I and a lot of people on the left are
saying, like all look like it's funny, like,
look, there's this infighting, no unity among
the right.
But I'm a little worried about it because
from my perspective, it doesn't seem like
it's just harmless infighting.
It seems like the right is actually consolidating
behind Nick Point and he's siphoning off support
from traditional conservatism.
Let me ask you, because you've got let me
ask you a question.
What percentage of this country do you believe
knows who Nick when Tess's.
All well, right now, not that high.
But when you go online, he's a very, very
popular figure.
Right.
I that.
I think here's my view on this.
I think this is not a perfect analogy by any
means, but in the same way that.
If you just pay attention to Twitter and read
it, you probably had the impression during
the Democratic primary that Bernie's support
was dramatically higher than what it really
ended up being in the primary.
A lot of the slivers of the right are essentially
unknown in popular culture outside of certain
on claims.
And in fact, there are tons of people in my
audience who are involved in the online political
space who also have no idea who Nick when
as is.
I mean, I know who he is, but I don't follow
him in any way.
So I understand the concern.
And there's no doubt that if support on the
right starts to consolidate around movements
like that, it would be a
very, very scary thing.
Right now, I don't think it's going on.
Now, that doesn't mean it won't happen and
that doesn't mean we don't need to be worried
about it.
But I think that we really don't want to overstate
the power of these movements when when it
doesn't deserve to be overstated.
That's a good point.
But I guess my bigger question was, what can
the left's strategy be?
Because what I've noticed is that a lot of
these people are anti-capitalist and they
advocate for a lot of the same positions that
we on the left for free college, free college
healthcare, but only for white people like
Nick one.tel's himself.
So and we've seen that in Europe, too.
So how does the left respond to that?
Well, so.
So one other thing is, I don't know that the
left has to respond to fights that right now
are mostly within the right.
I actually think it's smarter for the left
to stay out of it completely and let them
destroy themselves or weaken themselves to
the extent that they will.
If at a certain point, though, it goes more
mainstream, which I think is what your concern
is.
Then the left will have to put together a
strategy.
Now, if you check out my clip from earlier
this week, populism may be destroying social
democracy.
I think part of it is the left shouldn't get
pulled in too exclusively populist rhetoric
which can be repurposed, as you're pointing
out, by bad actors like, for example, free
college for everyone except as long as you're
white.
We want to stick with the policy based approach
of social
democracy.
But but that's going to be a bigger question
for the future.
All right.
Well, thank you for taking my call, David.
Appreciate the call.
Great to hear from you.